alright guy is with us in Missouri
hey Eric Oh welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show are you better than I deserve
what's up well I was calling I actually
have two questions my husband and I are
in the process of purchasing his family
business for a total of $600,000 and my
two questions his parents do not want us
to take it off early they said that
basically it's their retirement and so
my question two questions my first
question is how does that work at the
baby baby steps Ron Davey step two
currently and the second is in my head I
have it I thought it out to where will
wherever it will cause my baby steps we
will save up money in Park it somewhere
and the payment will come out of that
but I wouldn't know where to park it
deal is the deal closed no not yet good
you probably consider should consider
not doing it
why is that because you're getting ready
to step into a mess of six hundred
thousand dollars in that with people who
don't want you to pay it off that's
financial suicide no think about it
and you this isn't it you guys are
acting like this is nothing it's not
nothing it's six hundred thousand
dollars it's his mommy his mommy
oh my god yeah so let's try let me try
this again okay if I were in your shoes
unless I could get two things straight I
would have to walk away thing number one
is worry we are going to pay you off
early as a matter of fact we're going to
pay you off so fast it's going to be
scary and you're going to take that
money and invest it and live off of
those investments not off of me being in
debt to you that is asinine
okay and there isn't the very premise
that it's based on will get you in
trouble but also you know Thanksgiving
dinner is not going to taste this
as for the next 30 years you'll be
sitting there with people you owe
hundreds of thousands of dollars to bad
bad bad relationship management had
business management bad everything so
they they're worried about this as their
retirement well if I hand you six
hundred thousand dollars I can help you
retire by investing that without having
to be in debt without your kids having
to be in debt to you that's a ridiculous
statement thing number two what do you
have do you have any idea what the
actual net profit of this business is
yes we have the it was a hundred
thousand dollars last year and when it's
not worth well the way it is they're
buying or buying the inventory
everything doesn't matter everything in
it no matter that business is not worth
600 if it's only making a hundred it's
worth four hundred and ax if you want if
it's worth more to buy by getting all
the inventory would be better off to
sell off a bunch of the inventory okay
okay let me tell you let me stop using
okay if I'm an investor and I were going
to buy this business which I am an
investor it's what I do okay if I were
going to buy this business and the book
value of the business meaning the
inventory and the assets and the
receivables anything else the business
owns is worth more than the business is
worth due to its income then I would not
buy it to run it I would buy it to break
it up
meaning I would buy it I would close it
and I would sell off all the stuff and
that would put give me a better return
on my money than keeping it open so
you're telling me there's six hundred
thousand dollars worth of stuff there in
an inventory and so forth yes Book value
yes no book value book value is over a
million what are you calling Book value
then you've got inventory and so they
own a whole bunch of stuff that's not
creating any income yeah and my
husband's got plans to like move
everything quicker
so how much of this million is inventory
it's right at a million is inventory and
then it like everything inside the walls
like the shelving the software why is it
why are they sitting on a million
dollars worth of inventory to create a
hundred thousand dollars worth income I
mean I honestly so your husband is
really you ought to be sitting on maybe
maybe a hundred and fifty thousand to
two hundred thousand dollars worth of
inventory to create a house worth of
income okay you see what I'm saying yeah
you will never take a million dollars
and put it into something that you made
ten percent return on it in a small
business setting ever you would need you
want to make thirty forty fifty percent
rate of return on it in a small business
setting because you have all these other
costs involved too and so you're buying
a pig in a poke here you got a mess this
business is not healthy okay you
following me yeah no I follow okay
now if you were gonna buy a business
based on Book value you pay it you buy
it based on what it's worth and you sell
the stuff off now if you want to keep it
open and sell the stuff off and get it
down and bring the business back to
health that would be a strategy you
could use if you were going to buy a
business that makes a hundred thousand
dollars in net profit usually a twenty
five percent rate of return which would
indicate a four hundred thousand dollar
value a twenty percent rate of return
would indicate a half a million dollar
value okay so not counting the fee so
you're buying a business that the income
does not justify the value the valuation
only the inventory and Book value does
which means the business has it has a
disease it's sick you follow my concepts
yeah okay which means you're walking
into a danger zone and you're about to
be in debt to your mother-in-law in a
danger zone who doesn't want you to pay
this off so my initial reaction was
correct and that you've got to
restructure this into a way that even
even if all is forgiven it in the event
that both of them passed doesn't matter
what if the business doesn't make a
profit your six hundred thousand dollars
that you can't even service it with the
income you got coming in yeah so here's
what I would do here's what I would do I
would do the deal but it is the the
payments on the 600 are number one no
prepayment penalty and I'm going to
prepay you and you're gonna take that
money and invest it to live on okay we
are not going to keep this debt if you
have to keep the debt don't do the deal
I would never tell you to do that beg
you not to do that number two if you can
get that part fixed then the second
thing I would do when you closed on it
the first order of business and within
six months is sell six hundred thousand
dollars worth of inventory out of there
cut the inventory down to four hundred
thousand because you do not have a turn
rate you didn't that inventory is not
turning off those shelves it's sitting
there collecting dust we know that
because it's not creating a profit and
so you've got to cut this inventory down
to about forty percent of what it is and
by the way you shouldn't sell off this
inventory and give a hundred percent of
it to mama and pay her off okay
so which is really what they should do
before they sell it to you and then just
give you the business if they were smart
but they're not gonna do that because
you're going to talk them through this
and I'm not even sure y'all are gonna do
any of this but that's what I would tell
you to do I would beg you not to be in
debt to your parent in loss it's going
to create problems you have no idea we
work with family businesses all over
America it's a disaster when you do this